e
e e
okay
folks can you hear me
I was going to turn
around
okay there's some semesters where early
in the semester you know it's going
going to be a not boring
semester this one is not going to be a
boring semester I mean last week we had
deep sea rocking the boat right this
week will have tariffs what will next
week bring God Only
Knows don't view it as a problem it's an
opportunity you live in these moments
this is when you learn the most about
Corporate Finance about decision making
anybody can make decisions when
everything is setled dead so embrace the
moment as I said no it's it is it is
what it is and your companies the
companies you pick will change over the
course of the next 15 weeks so I'm going
to start with two questions I'm going to
start every one of the next four
sessions with how many of you have
picked a
company
okay how many of so relatively few that
question is going to become how many of
you have not picked a company by next
week cuz I hope by then most of you have
picked a company don't play Hamlet don't
try to think about the perfect company
to pick pick a company start working on
it because as you will see today what we
talk about in class you can apply on
your company if you can do it in real
time right after class it's so much
easier than waiting till week 12 or 30
okay the second is if you've picked a
company and I want to ask you this
question please go into that Master list
and enter the name of your company
you're not going to be held accountable
to that to that because you can change
your mind this is just for me to track
what you're doing and across the
companies and if in week seven you
decide to change your company that's
perfectly okay I just want to make sure
that Master list is going to become
where you go in and Chronicle what
you're finding about your company over
time so it's going to build up up over
time so right now all you have is the
name of the company and then as we go
through each section if you're keeping
up you can fill in the numbers then but
by week 15 you better have them all
filled up because that's going to be a
project that's going to be the numbers
in your project so we were talk we were
starting our discussion of corporate
governance any administrative questions
before we
start I might have mentioned this last
week but I mention again if you're not a
Stern student and you're not getting the
emails the reason is very simple it goes
through a an alias I don't actually have
an email list it actually goes through a
school Alias that's maintained as a
Google Group which the school maintains
in theory that's supposed to be matched
up to the
registrations on Albert why in theory
because it is it so I will leave it at
that so somehow somewhere there can be
lags there can be and if you're a non
Stern student you will not be getting
the emails because you have an nyu.edu
address not a stern. nyu.edu address but
the minute you registered in this class
you were assigned to stern. nyu.edu
address and that's why I sent you that
link of course you are not getting the
emails you can't use the link but so
come and talk to me if you're not
getting the emails there is a way you
can find out what your Stern email
addresses and it's not just for being
able to get into the Google shared
spreadsheets it's for accessing Stern
data you need that Stern email
address so let's go back to where I left
you last session we're talking about
Disney's board in 1997 which I described
as one of the worst boards I've ever SE
seen created at a large publicly traded
company full of conflicts of interest
between what's good for shareholders and
what's good for Michael E it was a
rubber stampo in fact Let me let me let
me follow through on that and pile on
Disney because we're we're
in in 1997
Calpers anybody familiar with Calpers
what what is
scalpers what is it it's a pension fund
but who whose money does it
manage it's a California state pension
fund and California needless to say is a
big state it's one of the biggest State
Pension funds in the country and in the
last century they no longer do this they
used to be an activist Fund in other
words not only they invest they actually
got up and wanted to ask questions of
management so they held companies
accountable that's no longer the case
but in in 1997 they had a test for when
they looked at companies we ask three
questions the majority of directors in
this company a very lowlevel test
actually if you think about it are they
outside directors is the chairman of the
board independent of the CEO obviously
that can't be the case the chairman of
the the board is the CEO and thirdly is
the comp are the compensation and audit
committees composed entirely of
Outsiders very very low-level test
Disney was the only company in 1997 that
failed all three
tests since we're piling on let's keep
piling on in 1997 Business Week
ranked companies in terms of worst
BS Disney was in top 18t was trying
really hard to be the worst but they
know they was a contest all through the
'90s I'll be the worst you can be the
worst so Disney won that contest as well
so in 1997 Disney had a horrifically bad
board which was a rubber stand for the
CEO at the Time Michael
E that was 27 years ago right we'll talk
about the what happened in the
intermediate period but let me show you
the board as it stands
today first instead of 17 it's 12 that's
an improvement you don't have as big a
board
I'm not going to pass judgment on any of
these nice people I'm sure they are
really good people well
qualified but I'm going to ask you a
generic question you don't even have to
know anything about this board and this
is something I want you to think about
when you ask the question is my board
effective do you think Disney's board of
directors today is a good board of
directors I think it's a horrifically
it's it's competing with the 1997 board
he's saying that's pretty harsh because
they've really mangled corporate
governance at Disney over the last
decade I'm going to tell you the rest of
the story later but as you know the CEO
of Disney right
now is Bob
ier in 2011 Bob Iger you know Bob Iger
replaced Michael Eisen who a pretty so
we'll talk about what caused that
replacement and for the first few years
he was actually a very good CEO o and in
2011 he laid out a plan to have a su it
is a succession plan this is what good
CEOs do right he said look you know I've
been here for six years 10 is about the
maximum you should have CEO so in
2015 you should have the next CEO ready
and and the race got started within
Disney right Tom's tags people were
really good rising up say I'm going to
be the next CEO and then the board did
something I think that is
unconscionable they went to Bob AER and
they
said Disney can't live without you
you're too important for Disney and he
said no no no no I'm not that important
and they kept doing it if you seen
Julius Caesar the the Shakespeare
version the first time they triy to make
him King I'm not worthy the second time
no no I'm not worthy the third time okay
so the third time they asked him he said
I'll stay on and it triggered an entire
implosion in in Disney because when he
chose to stay on remember all those
people had had been lined up they all
said look we're not going to wait around
they left they left a vacuum under Iger
and ever since the question is there's
nobody to replace aiger he has to stay
on in 2020 AA did surprise Everybody by
doing
what he left and he picked a replacement
the board went along Bob chapek a guy
who's very competent but not really
suited to be the CEO of a company like
Disney where you got a balance Bob CH
was a finance guy who ran theme parks he
basically got you know now he's a CEO of
the company picked by the board replace
Iger and then he went on this ill- fated
expedition of Disney plus and spend as
much M money as you can to sign up more
subscribers almost drove Disney into the
ditch because they took the cash from
the other businesses and sunk into
streaming clearly was not
sustainable so in
2022 AA never gave up his office at
Disney which tells you something about
this transition not really being a
transition 2022 AA said I'm coming back
and the boat said welcome back we're in
2025 and there's talk that AA will leave
in 2026 my son works at Disney you know
everybody saying will he leave will he
not leave the question is for him to
leave what has to be done you have to
find a
replacement with this board I'm not sure
you'll get there so in
2045 AO will be in a senior home running
Disney and the board will say any day
now we'll come up with the CEO the way
you measure the effectiveness of a board
is not by how it looks or who's on the
board or how independent it is but how
effective it is it's to answer the
question the case of Disney the actions
gave them away but I want you to think
about and this is why I wanted to pick a
company quickly is when you pick a
company I wanted to take a look at the
board of directors of the
company and see if you can find some
information about the board of directors
and at least in the US you will find
that there are ways you can uncover
information on the board of directors us
companies are required to file with the
SEC a filing called the 14 Def One for
DF it's supposed to list out every Board
of every director on the board and give
you in detail what their connections are
with the company or the CEO and you know
what you know companies are very open
they reveal everything because they know
people don't read disclosures that's one
of the problem I call this disclosure
diarrhea is you disclose everything and
you get lawyers to write it make it 300
Pages nobody's going to read it and that
affect ly works every time but I wanted
to take a look at that 14 you're saying
what if I have a foreign
company well you might not be able to
find information on conflicts of
interest but that by itself is revealing
right what does it tell you when you
cannot find anything about the board of
directors so remember the the Sherlock
Holmes novel I forget which one it is a
Hound of the basals maybe now of course
you you the Sherlock Holmes storyline
always runs the same Sherlock and
his his and Watson walk and Watson of
course has to act like the dummy as it's
why what and Sherlock tells him it's a
brilliant guy so this is a murder that's
happened in a house where nobody could
get in somebody in the house did the Mur
but nobody knows it at the beginning the
way Sherlock solves it is the key clue
is the dog did not bark
of course if this dog
were lab or golden retriever it doesn't
barket anybody anyway but in this story
it was significant but the fact that the
dog did not bark was indicative of the
fact that the dog was really good
friends with whoever
broken this was the key clue the fact
that you cannot find information about
something is
information and you will find yourself
running into this when you do your
research in your companies I can't find
anything about my company congrat
congratulations that tells you something
about corporate governance at this
company when you can't uncover anything
so take a look at who your board is
there are corporate governance scores
out there and I'll send you some some
links to these y you can pull them up of
Yahoo but basically these are services
that measure corporate governance I
wouldn't throw them further than I can
because really they don't measure much
but they do all the checkbox stuff right
the independent is meet so it meets all
the criteria for what a good board is
supposed to be based in academic
research so I'll send you the score but
most of all I want you to focus on in
your
company is your board an effective board
that's what I want you to keep your eyes
on not whether it's independent not
whether you know what it looks like but
what does it do because a good board
acts as a check on
management so with that lead and let's
talk a little bit about in the real
world now that we've established that
neither the annual meeting nor the board
of directors are that effective at
keeping managers in line
yes in a
private in a private company who's in
who's the owner of the
company the person running the company
right so in a sense I I don't care if he
wants to ruin himself by picking a bad
board why should you get in the way of
somebody who's intent on making
themselves poor you can't stop them so
in a private business a board of
directors is more like a Consulting arm
rather than a governance arm right so
I'm not surprised in private companies
the bo so it could be Consulting it
could be networking because you have
connections so board of directors in a
private company faces a very different
set of rules than the board of directors
in a publicly traded company so if
you're the owner of company how should I
compose a good board my advice you find
good smart people who will ask you tough
question just like in a public company
but there it's not about protecting some
abstract shareholders interest about
protecting your own interest it's in
your own best interest to have people
asking you tough questions but as human
beings we know that that's what we claim
we want but in practice that's not what
we end up looking for so you can't
control what own
so if shareholders have little power
over managers you know what managers do
they put their interest over shareholder
interest and again this is not passing
judgment on the morality or ethics of
managers it's human nature to put
self-interest first and let's look at
some examples of managerial Interest
being put over shareholders interest the
first is the practice of green mail what
is green mail it's just like black male
but it's a lot more money and it's legal
so here's how it works yeah so it's
let's say it's the early 1980s you're a
top manager at an oil company in the US
it's been a good decade for you the
previous decade oil prices have gone up
and when oil prices go up you make a lot
of money without even
trying so you wake up in your house when
BR Brentwood you work at unal which at
that time was in Southern California you
wake up in your house in Brentwood at
10:30 why what are you going to do
getting into work anyway watch the oil
price terminal a little more
closely and while you're drinking your
coffee you read a news story it says ke
Boon
Pickin
announces a hostile acquisition bid for
unal the way this works is when you're
an investor who's trying to know or any
anybody trying to make a hostile
acquisition but when you get to 5% of
the shares of a company you got to
announce to the world what your
intentions are because you can say look
I want to own just 5% or I'm going to
take over the company and he's called a
press conference because he got to the
5%
threshold cost him about $100 million to
get to that 5% and he's gone public with
why he plans to take over the company
and the way he starts is this is the
most badly managed Oil Company in the
world I plan to take it over and change
it you spit out your coffee you jump
into your car you drive as fast as you
can top management meeting called Full
attendance for the first time in I don't
know how long everybody's there why cuz
your jobs are threat right you are the
top management he was talking about and
you devise a plan and here's your plan
you will approach Mr Pickins and make
him an offer he cannot refuse or he can
but it'll cost him a lot basically you
tell him that you will buy out his the
100 million that he spent on the sh
those shares for $200
million and just to make sure because in
blackmail the problem is you pay
blackmail they back at you again and
again and again this time you have a
lawyer with you and they sign what's
called a stand agreement which means
that if you buy the shares back Boon
Pickins can't buy shares in your company
for the next five
years you approach Boon picket you offer
him 200 million he takes the money this
is easy money right
of course there's a whole line of
activist investors now lined up saying
this company is a py let's buy because
remember the stal agreement doesn't stop
other people but that's a different game
you've just paid green mail why because
you paid the 200 million so he will not
take and why do you do it let's play a
game Let's suppose I am the CEO of
unical your shareholders in unal and you
asked me why do you do it and I said I
did it for you and you said what I said
my I took $200 million of your money and
I made sure Bo Pickins wouldn't do an
acquisition where he paid you $5 more
than the market price and you say you
did what to do what this doesn't sound
like you're getting anything out of this
right very clearly they did it for one
reason and one reason all which is to
protect their jobs which is fine but if
you're going to do this I want to
liquidate your portfolios and sell your
houses and use your money to protect
your jobs not your shareholders do
money that's green
man closely behind that are golden
parachutes what are golden parachutes
after hostile acquisition what happens
people lose their jobs
right so before it happens here's what
you do first you go to a lawyer right
after an acquisition and this is key you
do it after an acquisition has been
announced you run to your lawyers and
retroactively you put into your
compensation agreement a clause that if
your company take over you get 20
million 15 million 5 million 10 million
depending on where you are in the
hierarchy the Only Rule is the higher up
the more money you get when Revlon was
targeted for a hostile acquisition in
the
1980s those golden parachutes that's
what they called collectively cost the
company 150 million let's take that back
it doesn't cost the company companies
have no money you know who it cost right
the shareholders in the company because
when the acquisition was done it was
lower by 150 m million because all these
people had to be paid
off these
are the most egregious because
shareholders don't get to vote on these
the board of directors has to go along
but we saw what the board of directors
look
like the next two are a little less
egregious because shareholders have to
vote for these you're given a right to
stop it most of the time shareholders
don't seem to stop and we can talk about
why one is a poison pill if you look at
terminology around m&a it is this
strange combination of medieval times
and James Bond
movies there are white knights riding in
shooting guns I mean I don't think
you're mixing up the centuries here you
know what a poison pill is you're the
potential Target for a hostile
acquisition you want to make yourself
unpalatable to the acquir a poison pill
is something you put within your company
the acquirer says I don't want to touch
the company I'll give you an example you
know what a right and you're familiar
with rights offerings in in a typical
company here's how a rights offering
works I have a stock that trades at $10
you're all shareholders in the company I
give you the right to buy an additional
share every one of you an additional
share at
$5 would you exercise the right you
better right because if you don't you're
leaving $5 I'll even let you sell the
right to somebody else for roughly $5
it's a way of raising Equity Capital
where you don't have to really hire an
investment Bank it kind of goes through
that's a typical rights off
but here's how a poison pill rights
offering is going to look like your Shar
is trade at $10 I give you the right to
buy an additional share at 100 you're
saying why would I want that right as
long as I run the
company but if somebody else runs a
company the rights price drops from $100
to $1 you see what I've done right I've
created something that's completely
useless as long as I run the company
valueless but the minute somebody takes
over the company it blows up on that
because they buy 51% of the shares they
think they've acquired the company and
all of a sudden all these rights show
up it's a poison pill that requires
shareholder approv okay and you have
Shar
repellant Shar repellant again are anti-
takeover amendments you put into your
corporate charter that make it more
difficult for some body to take take
over your company the standard in
Acquisitions you have to get 51% of the
shares to buy the company you could put
in a clause in the corporate charter
that says you need 80% of the shares to
take over the company or the normal way
a takeover works and you take over the
company replace the board of directors
you create a board of directors with
rolling terms where the the acquirer has
to wait four years to replace the board
of directors all designed to slow the
process down that two requires
shareholder approve you're saying why
would shareholders approve things that
work against their
interest because here's how I I as the
management team will describe these
these add-ons they say look if you give
me these tools I will negotiate an even
better price for you on the acquisition
and you trust
me and then of course there is to me the
most egregious example of putting
manager interest over shareholder
interest which is what happen happens
around every
acquisition especially friendly
Acquisitions friendly merges are two
companies have you ever seen a merger
announcement where the managers of
either the acquiring or the target
company describe the merger as a bad
merger it wouldn't make sense right they
all claim amazing things will happen
Synergy all this amazing value will be
created and you fall for it every single
time not really we don't fall for it but
at least a PR machine rolls out but the
truth is that most mergers don't work
especially public to public
companies how do we know they don't work
first you look at what happens to the
market price of the acquiring company
Target company always everybody wins
right because but you look at the
acquiring company you get that immediate
judgment the market is making about
their acquisition in what way whether
the acquiring Company stock price
increases or decreases it's a very very
simple indicator if you announce a big
acquisition and your stock price drops
3% I don't care how nicely you describe
this merger people are not buying
it so I'm going to take you back to you
know to an example to illustrate this
but we know that at the time of the
merger many shareholders are much more
skeptical about the benefits than the
managers are but if you ask managers
then about that you know what their
response is right they don't see what we
see
which is what all these spreadsheets the
bankers have come up with showing us how
much Synergy there is in the merger we
see that they don't and technically
that's true shareholders don't have as
much information as managers
do but here's a another set of tests
which are even more Dam so you can take
that on the day of the acquisition and
say markets don't really they're
irrational that's short term but if you
track merges five or 10 years after the
merger if your sales pitch on the merger
was actually had some bases what should
we see the combined company should do
better than the pure group there should
be higher profits Synergy actually plays
out and both McKenzie and KPMG have done
these studies repeatedly over time and
they conclusively find that if you track
merges five or 10 years out that in 83%
of merges there is no
Synergy or reverse synergy one in six
merges there Synergy where everybody
talks about it rare in
practice and half of all merges are
reversed within 5 years of a merger
where the quaran company says it didn't
work so I'm going to take a merger from
way back in
time but it's a merger that kind of
illustrates this process playing
out in 1987 Eastman Kodak was actually
considered one of the best managed best
run companies in the United States
in the early '70s one of the nifty50 one
of the great companies of Polaroid
Eastman
Kodak and what business was Eastman
Kodak in
1987 cameras
film and it was a legendary company in
terms of how well it was run but things
were starting to slow down why because
the Japanese camera makers had come with
cheaper cameras and and cheaper film
Eastman Kodak was a profitable company a
well-regarded company but with low
growth so what do middle-age people do
they go to plastic surgeons what do
middle-age companies do they go to
Consultants I don't know who the actual
consultant
was but it might have been BCG remember
the BCG Matrix have you seen this with
the know know cows dogs pigs wandering
around it's like a farmyard in there but
basically idea was if you have a cash
cow company you want a star in your
orbit you can almost see the consultant
doing it you can almost see Eastman
codex management eyes widening said we
could do this we want to buy a star you
know who the stars were in
1987 pharmaceutical companies it was the
start of the healthc Care boom Supreme
pricing power they said we need to buy a
drug company I'm sure somebody in the
audience said how will we frame the
synergy
between a camera company and a drug
company and I'm sure the concern would
have come up with a really creative way
you'll deliver the drugs through the no
whatever the viewer or whatever it is no
but we frame The Story So Eastman Kodak
goes out and decides to buy this company
called Sterling
drug and it gets into a bidding war if
you're ever in m&a and you're in a
bidding war you've already lost this
battle they get into a bidding war with
a Swiss farmer company called Hoffman L
Ro now Sterling Drugs when when you
started was about trading about $40 per
share the bidding what they keep pushing
the price up Hoffman L stops bidding but
Eastman Kodak seems to have missed that
and kept bidding it's like being on eBay
and you keep bidding against
yourself eventually they win at 8950
Supreme Victory the next day Wall Street
Journal runs a headline Eastman Kodak
wins bidding war
and in the day they win won the bedding
War this is what happened to Eastman
kodak's stock price they lost
collectively $2.2 billion in one day
they probably wiped out 15 years of
careful project analysis with one big
bad
deal this might have been pure
coincidence but you looked at the
premium they paid over the $40 in market
cap terms they paid a 2.1 billion this
is is looking suspiciously like a zero
sum game right if you pay 2.1 billion
more than what something is worth it has
to come out of your money saying where's
the extra 100 million well the bankers
have to be paid the Consultants have to
be paid this an expensive
process this one deal I know it's it's
it's you know I'm using the benefit of
hindsight I
think turn the tide on Eastman Kodak
where is Eastman Kodak now you can go to
Rochester with the magnifying where is
Eastman C I mean the company is pretty
much done right the most valuable thing
about the company is its
name when is the last time you bought a
Kodak camera do they even make that film
I don't know what they do
anymore so this was at the time of the
acquisition of course at the time of the
acquisition Eastman Cod act said there's
lots of synergy amazing things are going
to happen so first let's track what
happened to Sterling drugs in the years
because they kept it as a
division sometimes you don't have the
benefit of tracking the division so this
is what the revenues and operating
income look like Sterling Drugs and I
don't even need a magnifying glass to
tell you there's nothing there there's
no Synergy there there Synergy you
should have seen an increased profit or
higher growth neither showed
up and of course along the way all
Eastman Kodak said this is amazing you
know we'll turn it around just still
early in the process
in fact in 1993 rumors started floating
around that Eastman Kodak was shopping
Sterling drug around looking for a buyer
when those rumors came out the chairman
of Sterling Winthrop which was the
division of Eastman Kodak with the
Sterling drug said now massive
speculation Which flies in the face of
the stated intent of Kodak that it's
committed to be in the health business
remember the old Soviet saying never
believe anything until it's officially
denied it's been officially denied of
course it turned out just a few months
later that the Eastman
Kodak sold off Sterling Drugs for 1.7
billion you know how much they paid for
it up front 5.2 billion you pay 5.2
billion in
1987 you get back 1.7 maybe two billion
if you add up everything back in 93 you
don't need any internal rate of return
calculations to know this is one screwed
up deal right of course at the time it
happened Samu lle and I don't know Sam
I'm sure he's a nice guy said this is
very good for sopi and very good for
Kodak but he said the same thing in 1987
when so clearly it must be something a
script reads out are very good very good
no matter what you do very good for the
company this was one screwed up deal
saying why did they do
it cuz you wanted to manager of a high
Growth Company it's so much more fun
right you can all this neat
stuff I know it's cynical but I'm
naturally a cynical person but in many
cases when you look at corporate actions
you ask why did they do it we try to
dress it up in terms of be it being good
for the company and good for the
shareholders the truth is it has nothing
to do with them there's another agenda
at play where managers ask what's good
for me and they try to bring it into
theis so if your company moves its
headquarters to Veil
Colorado and you said why would they do
it maybe you should check out your CEO's
Instagram post and see if he does a lot
of skiing maybe he just likes to ski out
of the headquarters down a slope and he
says this would be good for
me but if you don't have any power over
manages that's exactly what they're
going to do so here's what I'd like you
to look at in your
company this of course requires you pick
a company I want you to look in your
company as where does the power lie
remember the old saying power abor of
vacuum confucious said that confuscious
never said that but you know you can
always attribute things to nobody knows
what he said but he seems to have said a
lot but power does a pour vacuum so
there's nobody in power somebody's going
to come in and exercise the power I want
you with your company to ask where does
the power lie and let me give you some
choices it can be with the shareholders
maybe your companies that classic sh you
know utopian Corporate Finance Company
your shareholders have a lot of power
I'll give you examples that you might
look at that'll that'll get you there
maybe it's inside shareholders as
opposed to outside shareholders you what
the heck are inside shareholders what is
the power line at
facebookm it lies with a group of
shareholders Mark zerber in particular
hold the high voting rights inside
shareholders versus outside shareholders
so could be shareholders or it could be
inside shareholders it could be managers
where you look at said nobody in this
company is going to really have the
incentive to challenge them managers run
the show it could be the government then
how would the government run a publicly
traded company you know through lots of
different things one is it could have a
golden share there are what used to be
government companies we'll talk about
example CH now publicly traded companies
where the government is veto power over
big decisions that the company makes
they're in theory publicly traded but in
practice the CEO is appointed by the
government the directors are appointed
by the government now you can take the
examples I'm going to use the example of
Val it could be LC in India basically
companies that are now publicly traded
you're saying so what hey he who pay you
know who controls the levs of power is
going to determine where the company's
headed so we'll talk about the corporate
finance consequences there are some
European companies where employee unions
essentially own enough shares that they
actually control the company you saying
this is good it is good for employees
but is it good for the company we'll
have to play it out in terms of where
that plays out and there are some cases
where lenders to the company actually
control the company usually what has to
happen for that to get
triggered it's not just indebted but you
got to have something you know some
legal consequence some Covenant you've
broken some legal consequence because
that's when the court step in and say we
can't trust these guys you can run the
company so I'm going to give you the
place I start with when I look at a
company to see where the power lies I
start by looking who the biggest
shareholders in the company are so let's
start with Disney in
2003 I'll show you Disney in 2003 2009
maybe 2014 and 2024 so you can see
what's changed over time if you take a
look at Disney in 2003 and it's a tough
page to read but after class today I
would in the email when I sent it you
this comes from Bloomberg and the nice
thing about have going to the Bloomberg
terminals there are four I think in this
building and I'll try to figure out
where they are so you can find them you
type in the name of your company okay
and you type in
HDs for the for your company you get the
top 70 it's an amaz you pick any company
in the world it'll give you the top 17
some of those lists are more reliable
than others
so God help you if you're looking up the
top 15 shareholders in a Zimbabwe and
Company because ultimately Bloomberg
gets us from public filings right so
these are the top 17 shareholders in
Disney what do you notice a lot of 13fs
you're saying what the heck is a 13f
those are filings made by mutual funds
or institutional investors with the SEC
I told you they you know Bloomberg gets
data so 16 of the top 17
shareholders in Disney are big
Institutional Investor
there's one poor individual hanging out
it's Roy Disney how did he get his
shares he inherited them
right so who owns shares in Disney a lot
of institutional investors and remember
what we talk said about institutional
investors they tend to vote with
incumbent managers and with their
feet however Disney share order in 2003
which I was not my stomach would have
dropped the minute I saw this list
because who's fighting for my for me no
nobody there right this is going to be a
company where the board is a rubber
stamp board and you essentially have
very little to say my guess is you type
the top 17 shareholders in Nestle or
Unilever or any of these old public late
or even you know Coca-Cola will talk
about who might show up in the name who
might give you some hope but he's 92
years
old what am I talking about what you
know you type Coca-Cola stop sh who do
you see the first you see you w see
Warren Buffet you will see burshire hat
away so first you have to know that that
and you say please please God let Warren
Buffett actually be showing up and
asking questions no might be just faint
hope but you so you're looking to see is
there anybody on this who will be
fighting my fight they it's not because
they're thinking about you you see car I
can in the list you should be happy not
because car I can thinks about you he
doesn't even have time to think about
you he thinks about himself but you're
going along for the
right let's move to
V first problem with v is two class of
shares already my hopes have dropped one
class has no voting rights and the other
has all of the Voting Rights and in or
willan
twist the shares without voting rights
are called preferred
shares your preferred shareholder why
why because you don't have voting rights
okay you get some dividends up front
just to keep you
happy and then you have the voting right
shares and they're basically not even
accessible to the public they're held by
six major
entities one of which is the Brazilian
government and to add to all of that the
Brazilian government preserves what's
called a golden share which essentially
means that V can't do anything of
consequence without the Brazilian
governments
why did this happen while used to be a
government owned company wasn't a
publicly traded company transitioned
privatized but it still remains a
company where the government essentially
drives a few years ago maybe a decade
ago I wrote a piece on Petro brush which
has very much the same structure AS Val
and I wrote the piece because we
remember that first principal page in
corporate finance let's suppose you
wrote a perverse version of that page
and here's what it would look like your
investment principle is find Investments
that earn less than your hurdle rate
your financing mix is borrow money till
your cost of capital goes through the
roof and your dividend principle is pay
out cash even if you don't have
it Petras seem to be falling that
perverse P so why would it do
that when companies do perverse things
it's because the incentive structure is
screwed up so you're the CEO of Petr
there's only one man that time I think
it was a man you had to keep happy and
he sat in Brazilia he was the minister
of finance of the Brazilian
government and at that time the
Brazilian government was very open about
the fact that they wanted prass to be
the largest oil company in the world not
the most profitable not the best run the
largest oil company so you know what
Petr BRZ did they were looking for oil
everywhere even if it was not viable
they said we need
oil they behaved exact ly the way you'd
expect them to given the incentive
structure so if you're looking at a
company and it's doing all these
perverse things and why would they be
doing it look at where the power lies
who do they answer to at V if you're a
shareholder if you try to buy shares and
I used to be a shareholder in val for a
while the only shares you're going to
get are voting or the non- voting shares
let's say you go through an an ADR you
actually buy shares even in in in Brazil
you're going to buy the non-voting
shares no you will have it said no
power let's move on to tart Motors I
pulled up the top 17 I noticed a strange
phenomenon there were a lot of t
companies among the top
17 this is not a
conspiracy it's a reflection of their
history until about 40 years ago maybe
even 35 years ago these were all almost
entirely still privately owned Tata
companies so if TARTA Steel needed to
build a plan and didn't have the money
know what the family did they took the
money out of Tata Motors and they put
into Tata steel the accounting
transaction was TARTA Motors got a piece
of tataa Steel this is a reflection of
History which means the older TARTA
company is the more of these cross
Holdings you're going to get in fact the
TARTA company with the least of cross
Holdings is TARTA Consulting Services
the youngest and the biggest of the
group but let's focus on the corporate
governance aspect of it if if five or
six and I think I've highlighted the T
if six of the top 17 largest
shareholders in your company are other
companies in the Tata
group remember we talked about what's
good for the company versus what's good
for the family group what t t
Motors Tata chemicals or Tata steel
would do has nothing to do with what's
good for the company and everything to
do with what's good for the group again
it's to too early to if that's true but
you're framing the discussion so when
you see those things happen say okay
that's why it's
happening there's nothing that t modus
does of any
consequence that at that time rat t on
the top floor hasn't signed off there's
no way you could do
it but when I did this I think I did a
corporate finance session for a group of
Indian Indian managers their response
was but it's a benevolent it's a good
family and that's true among family
groups in India the Tata group is
considered a benevolent
group there are other family groups you
wouldn't even touch with the 10 foot
pole I won't name them was a benevolent
group and it did look benevolent right
there was so if you played it through
you looked at the the setup it's very
convoluted all these family group
companies have all these structures
they've set up and for a while the
benevolence kind of carried the day
right
and then in 2015 or 16 cus mystery who
was actually part of is related to the
TS was CE of the company an internal
corporate governance struggle happened
and we saw the family kind of throw its
power in and no we don't want that CEO
we don't want that decision
making you know I I frame this question
of corporate
governance similar to the way you frame
the Democracy Wass is authoritarian
regime
choice now if I ask you would you rather
live in a democracy or would you rather
live in an authoritarian regime what are
we all trained to say oh democracy we
love freedom but let's face it democracy
comes with a lot of chaos right we get
to pick but we sometimes make bad picks
and we got to live with them and then we
got to replace the
picks wouldn't it be nice if we were all
like Singapore
it's in principle it's a a Lia new
dictatorship sounds awfully good in
these days of chaos doesn't it you will
never have admit it because it's not
supposed to be something you accept in
polite company but the truth is we all
are the seeking for a benevolent
dictator an emperor who will make the
right choices without all this mess of
Elections and Chaos that's the push and
pull you see when you look at corporate
governance
that we want a benevolent CEO we'll give
him all the powers or her all the powers
what does it matter that you have a
board of directors they're going to do
the right thing
anyway in 2012 when Facebook went public
it created two classes of shares and I
blame Google for this you're saying
what's Google got to do with it because
until 2004 this was not done in the US
to be listed on the New York Stock
Exchange you could not have dual class
of shares there are companies like four
that were grandfather in no and since
every company in the US the way you
climb through the ranks you got list in
the NASDAQ but you ultimately wanted to
be on the NYC companies didn't have
shares with different voting rights then
Google came along and said we're going
to have two class of
shares and they said you won't be
listening on NYC they said we don't care
we'll be on the NASDAQ who cares and the
N NASDAQ for Fairly Craven reason said
we're okay with multiple class of
shares the door had been open and at
that time institutional investors had
said no we won't buy these shares
because you're treating as a second
class citizens but they went along why
because Google was run by good
managers this was the age where the tech
CEO was just below God I think or maybe
on Parallel Tech CEOs could do no wrong
2012 same phenomenon plays out with
Facebook Mark Cleber shows up remember
the sweat shirt for his
IPO I know people on Wall Street said
guy's not wearing a suit other people
said that's so cool look at Tech CEO
is's young he's
brilliant and at that time again
institutional investors jumped and I
said you know aren't you guys worried
about the fact that Zak has 57% of
voting rights I said no he's such a good
manager he's a benevolent CEO only
problem with most director most
dictators is you start benevolent but at
some point in
time I'm sure Hugo Chavez when he first
came to Venezuela people was said this
guy is so amazing fresh air you know
he's making change he's doing the right
things somewhere along the way it goes
to their heads and they become
malevolent right lianu is the
exception you're more likely to have a
Hugo Chavis then it leak one
you so in 2020
one remember the metaverse Fiasco at
Facebook stock price collapses of course
was a incredibly badly managed exercise
spending aund billion doar in the
metaverse without telling anybody the
what what the metaverse was or what how
you plan to make money on stock price
collapses student of mine who's a
Institutional Investor investing in
Facebook calls me and he says you know
Mark sule book is not listening to
us they said this is your
complaint buying Facebook shares and
complaining that Mark suberg is not
listening to like getting married to a
Kardashian and complaining that a camera
is following you all over the place what
did you think would
happen you give away power of course
he's not going to listen to you and it's
too late after the fact to have regrets
right you can't put the genie back I
have a I think we've created a problem
for El in the last 20 years with the
companies going public that many of them
are3 trillion companies and we have zero
zero power over these companies because
we've structured
it where the exit for the moment we
might be okay they're $3 trillion
companies but if they start doing things
you don't think they should be doing God
help
you which brings me to ba Buu in
2013 was was a NASDAQ listed company and
I told you what bu does there a search
engine that mostly Chinese people it's
basically almost all of its revenues
come from
China it was
traded in New
York and was incorporated in the Cayman
Islands it was a shell company the buyo
shares you were buying in New York were
actually not the shares in Buu the
operating company but in the Shell
company the Cayman Islands the shell
company that came in Island had
technically an agreement with the
operating company so it could but it's
technically that agreement was illegal
at least the Chinese government look the
other way because they
want you know how what a mind-boggling
exercise and risk-taking this is to buy
thousand shares in a company that's a
shell company hoping and praying that an
agreement that is technically illegal
will continue through
time first China big
Market but the problem is you could pick
the directors for the shell company but
they run nothing the people running BYU
were picked in China as the know by by
the then founder and essentially was a
company where the directors answered to
the founder they had absolutely no
allegiance to the shareholders in the
Shell company how much power do you have
as a shareholder in bu to change the way
the the actual companies run
zero now Alibaba was structured the same
way now they've moved the shell
Corporation to Hong Kong or somewhere
closer but you still have a shell
company you're buying shares and you're
not buying the actual
company so let's go back to Disney
things do change this is Disney in
2009 notice a big
shift who's at the top of the list of
Steve Jobs I thought he was CEO of Apple
how the hell did he become the large
shareholder in Disney anybody know the
backstory
yes he founded
Pixar and then he sold it to Disney and
how did Disney pay him in
shares overnight he became the largest
single you know what in 2009 I was a
Disney shareholder and I felt a little
better about being a Disney shareholder
not because Steve knows who I am but the
problem with entertainment companies in
fact with most middle-age companies they
get mired in inertia they do things the
way they and Disney was given its
history and its success was grounded in
inertia they did things exactly the same
way so they probably made animated
movies the way they made you know
Sleeping Beauty right people amazing art
form but people went long because
inertia is a comfortable thing there are
lots of words you can use to describe
Steve Jobs but he's not a he was never a
go along and get along kind of guy I
think and his history suggests that he
probably was sitting in the board
meeting saying why are you guys doing
that and he wasn't quiet about it it's
good to have somebody in the board who
is going to raise those issues I'm happy
to see Steve Jobs up there he's going to
shake it I mean I have no idea if he
actually did those board meetings are
confidential but I feel
better so that's the first linkage
managers and shareholders and you can
see if shareholders have little power of
managers managers put their interest
ahead I want you to assess in your
company here's the question you're
answering if I am a shareholder in the
company and some of you might actually
be shareholders in the company but if I
become a shareholder even if you're not
how much power would I have or or as
shareholders collectively would we have
to change the way management is behaving
if they're not behaving the way we want
them to that's basic so it's a Continuum
right from zero power in
val to maybe some power in Disney to
more power if you have a bill Amman or a
car aan on Amman on there so essentially
that's a question you're trying to
address is how much power will I have
let's move on to the second linkage
remember what we assumed about lenders
let lenders lend money to a firm and
they don't protect themselves what
happens them
nothing companies don't exploit the
loopholes and I said in the real well
that's not true you leave loopholes
somebody's going to exploit
them he's saying in what sense why W
stockholders and lenders be on the same
page because there are actions you can
take as a company where shareholders
might celebrate but lenders are going to
say don't do that so I want you guys to
think like a bank you guys to think like
Equity investor in the company right and
I'm going to go through a series of
choices where you have to tell me which
one you would pick if you got to pick
I'm thinking about paying a dividend or
even buying back money with four five
billion dollar a stock as lenders do you
want me to do that why
not Orin and cash leaves the company you
probably prefer that I never pay another
dividend never do a buyback and build up
cash to pay off interest you and the
other said give us our money back now we
can debate you know growth up but still
given a choice you can see why lenders
would never want you to increase
dividend not work so there's a potential
conflict of interest second one I come
to you with this really risky Endeavor
where Disney is going to enter the AI
business I don't even know whether
there's a business there but I'm going
to jump in anywhere it's a very Risky
Business lots of
upside but I'll have to spend tens of BS
what do you think of that
lenders in fact with Disney let's make
this Disney plus the streaming the
minute I announce I'm going to build
Disney plus and go for more subscribers
your probably gulping and said please
don't do
that you say what about the upside as
lenders why is the upside not attractive
to you because you don't get the
upside it's asymmetric you care about
downside and
finally if I borrowed money from you and
you didn't put in any covenants and I go
borrow more money on exactly the same
assets remember I've just transferred
wealth from You by making your debt more
risky you're on different page we're
going to come back and focus on this
conflict of interest the debt versus
Equity choice because obviously you as
lenders have to protect yourself and we
talk about what you can do to protect
yourselves but there is a conflict of
interest and if you don't protect
yourself it's going to come into play so
as lenders because Equity investors is
going to take advantage of you so I'm
going to give you a story that I hold on
to every time I hear a lender say I'm
lending to a company but it's okay
they're double a rated it's Triple A
rated they have a long history it's a
sad but true true story of RJR abisco in
the
1980s so let's go back 40 years you've
just
retired and you mooved to Florida why
you like to play
golf you've acquired a f know life
savings of $500,000 which was a lot of
money in the early 80s
and you found a broker and you said look
I want to invest this money initially
suggest Vanguard 500 Index Fund at that
time the only index one out there he
says no no no stocks for me because I'm
a retired person I need the cash flows
from this he suggest some corporate
bonds he said no no I don't want
corporates they're risky they they can
sometimes
defa and then He suggests one company's
bonds first the name of the company
attracts you it's RJR nisco why because
you've seen their name in groceries you
have nothing to do with Finance but no
it's been around a long time and then he
says it's a double a rated company have
no idea what he's talking about but he
follows up by saying no doublea rated
company has ever defaulted while it was
rated daa he's a very careful broker
that's technically true so you take your
half a million dollars you buy RJR
Nabisco bonds nice Safe Company long
history you go back to playing golf two
years later you come back from a golf
game you open up the Wall Street
Journal and you see a headline
KKR buys
RJ RJR with in an lbo you have no idea
what all these acronyms mean but you do
notice that RJ abisco the story you call
your broker and you say what happened
said technically
nothing you still own the same bonds you
did yesterday with the same coupon rate
you had yesterday but remember the
doublea that I talked about it's still
in the
alphabet but it slid a little bit it's
now Double B it's now riskier saying you
still have I mean no idea what that
means for you but if you take a double a
rated Bond you set a coupon rate becomes
a doubleb rated B riskier Bond what's
going to happen to the price of the
bond there's the RJR nisco price drop on
the day of the AL while equity research
analysts were celebrating RJ and abisco
bonds dropped 20% in value the stock
drops 20% you say that's okay it's but
this is a corporate bond a doublea rated
corporate
bond why did it happen because Nabisco
Bond buyers did not put in any
protections against this happening
because it never happened
before we're going to introduce a word
into the corporate finance lingo it's
nebis
code if you lend money to somebody and
you don't protect yourself you are are
going to get niis Cod I want this chart
to flash in front of your eyes next time
you're a banker saying lending to this
nice safe borrower he's never defaulted
before he's got this great
rating you're just asking to be Nabisco
if you don't protect
yourself so we talked about the first
linkage stockholders of little power
managers manages put their interest or
shareholder interest we talked about the
second one lenders lend money to a firm
and they don't protect themselves
they're going to get in a bis Cod
let's move to the third linkage in the
in theory at least here's how the
interaction between firms and financial
markets work out for publicly traded
firms if you're a company you go out and
tell the world what's happening to you
honestly and on time and markets are
rational and cool markets are efficient
what does that mean well markets are
efficient if you invest in good
long-term projects I should push up your
price inv in bad project I should push
down your price if you try accounting
gimmicks on me we'll talk about a few of
those gimmicks which make your earnings
look better but they're really not doing
much for your company I might punish you
actually rather than reward you and
stock price performance becomes a good
measure of whether you're doing your job
well as manag in theory that's the link
between market prices and the company
but in
practice lots of holes in those
assumptions let's start with the first
one do you think managers are honest
about revealing information to
company I'm going to surprise you for
the most part they
are they just don't do it in
time in fact when you think about the
kinds of things that managers do most of
the time it's not fraud fraud is still
the
exception it's holding back information
it's trying to control the flow of
information and who can blame them how
many of you are
married okay let's suppose during the
course of today you have some bad news
about your family
finances you get home at 6 or 7
tonight my advice is don't open those I
have some bad news this is not the way
to start the evening right so what do
you do you wait for a good
time you try after two glass of wine but
still not drunk enough so not not the
right time you wait and you wait and
then your spouse falls asleep and now
would be a good time and you whisper the
bad news news so that's the first
strategy right wait till your spouse is
asleep whisper the bad news and she says
I never heard or you know he said I
never I told you last
night the other is he tried to bundle
the bad news with some good
news hun I WRA the car around the tree
it's a bad news but I switched to
Geico completely
disproportional but you're hoping that
companies try exactly the same strategy
first is they try to find a good time to
reveal bad news they wait till the
Market's
sleeping in fact a few years ago it's a
long time ago I actually used to do
academic research I stopped that
practice about 20 years
ago you'd pick basically in academic
research you pick questions that
nobody's interested in you spend a
couple of years of your life researching
the question deeply then you write a
paper that 50 people
read and then you move on to this
exercise over and over I don't have time
for that as I said Life's too short so
this was early in my life I had to get
published to get
tenure so I picked a topic to look at
here's what I decid to look at I decid
to look at earnings and dividends
announcements made by companies by day
of the week see it's very high tech
definitely Nobel priz material
Monday Tuesday and I look to see what
kinds of news they contain in terms of
earnings and dividence so there Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday the
difference between those four days is
pretty minimal statistically they look
all the same and then you go to Friday
terrible things happen to companies on
Friday then you take a deeper look at
Friday it's not all day Friday it's
after 4
p.m. on Friday if you don't believe me
wait till Friday when the market closes
and then watch the new stories come out
terrible things happened you JP Morgan
some big fish ate up seven billion in a
bad trade in London came out after 4
p.m. on Friday what a company's hoping
you will do Forget by the time you come
back on Monday it never happens but
remember you know Mondays are the worst
day of the week to invest maybe this has
something to do with
it this is managers trying to control
the flow of
information human nature as I said once
in a while those though you do see
managers step over the line and they do
commit outright
fraud and when that happens eventually
the markets find out and the whole thing
blows up but managers are not
particularly good about revealing
information honestly and on
time and markets are not
exactly
ration I mean we built an entire body of
economics and Finance on the assump that
investors are collectively going to do
the right thing
right and I think there's lots of
different things you can look at said
that's not happening there so I'll give
you collectively three places where
researchers looked at what people do and
said that's not quite
rational and Robert Schiller went a
Nobel Prize for this know Taylor Richard
Taylor Chicago basically the whole body
of Finance built on the things I would
even call it irrational it's just human
beings doing human things and that's not
the way economists want you to do things
for instance there is evidence that when
you get big news
stories markets don't
overreact in both directions when there
are of course these subtext on
inefficiency where people are convinced
that insiders control the market this
has actually gotten worse over the last
20 years that there are these these
secret cabal of hedge funds that get
together I don't know where in New York
I'd love to drop in in that place that
they control the market that they make
tons of money of course it doesn't seem
to show up in their Alphas because
collectively hedge funds don't but
there's this notion that insiders and
there are some markets where this is
true where insiders actually control the
processes and third and this is I think
the critique that most people use
against markets is markets are shortterm
that if you trust market prices you're
encouraging companies to do short-term
things be honest
I mean in our gut we feel that's true
because we read news stories we see
opinion pieces so let's take a qu closer
look at this because I think this is at
the heart of should we trust market
prices this presumption that markets are
shortterm so I'm going to ask you a
series of questions you don't even have
to speak up just pick your answer as I
said there are no right answers don't
look at your neighbor I want you to go
with your gut right now so the first one
is that focusing on market
prices will make companies pick
shortterm over long term go with where
you are right now what you know about no
managers what you know about short-term
long-term everybody a chance to pick
that agree disagree second statement
remember if markets are not to be
trusted somebody has to make the
decision so the second one is is
allowing managers to do this going to
lead to more long-term
decisions than markets do again agree
disagree don't make a choice or the
third is maybe neither managers nor
markets can be trusted that that
government SL Regulators have to come in
and make you take decisions in the long
term the reason I want the reason I want
you to let let this this pot boil is
ultimately if you tell me markets are
shortterm even if I go along with it
remember I'm going to ask you who's
going to make the decisions instead
right is that group more long-term than
markets and that becomes a much tougher
call cuz I can give you lots of examples
where markets are shortterm I could give
you lots of examples of managers
shortterm I could give you lots of
examples of regulators and governments
are thinking about the next election
rather then the next what's good for the
long
term this is not remember the old um
milon fredman saying it takes a model to
be a model it takes a decision maker to
be the decision makers you don't like
managers tell me what you're going to
replace them with and we'll have to play
it out are they going to be more
longterm and then there is evidence that
and I'm going to say something with that
sometimes markets are way too
longterm I think they need to be a
little more shortterm where is it shop
now look at the valuation of some of
these young companies and superc
Computing companies I know took off two
years ago what did they do nobody's
quite clear what they do I don't think
they are quite clear what they do but
the supercomputing sounds awfully Hefty
right I mean it's something you know we
need
supercomputers so these are compan
companes which don't have a business
model perhaps not even a viable product
and they were collectively worth about
15 billion dollar if markets were truly
short term this company should be worth
nothing we're attaching a value that's
way too high so if you look at the
valuation of young companies the
argument can be that maybe we're
overvaluing this future growth and
potential and undervaluing what's on the
ground
today again not not perfect proof that
markets a long-term but something to
think about next second is if markets
are shortterm actions I take that
increase my current
earnings while reducing future growth
should be rewarded right shortterm
Market should say make make money now
and the evidence actually suggests again
the opposite that future growth is
valued much more highly than current
earnings in the market take a look at
Craft hins Company with Supreme current
earnings and compare it to palent all
growth right third if markets are
shortterm and I announce a decision
that's going to make my earnings lower
now but I do it for future growth and
R&D investment R&D is classic right
because when I spend money on R&D what
does it do it lowers my earnings today
and I said look you'll get future growth
markets are shortterm they should be
punishing me and you look at the market
reaction to Big investment announcements
which reduce your current earnings
increase future growth for the most part
the reaction is positive the only group
of um you know so this is in the short
term is blue the red is the long term so
four of those big longterm decisions
lowering current earnings getting future
growth Market says okay we'll push up
your price the one thing that doesn't
get
us you know his products right but
that's the emptiest of all announcement
I'm not even sure what it means right
doesn't require a big investment I'm not
sure about the growth so the next time
people say markets are shortterm push
back I not saying markets are longterm
but it seems to be more a belief markets
are short-term you're trained to do this
where is the basis for that other than
anecdotal
evidence and then of course people say
well what
about Market crisis like 2008 and 20
ready when markets melt down saying
isn't this the reason we shouldn't trust
markets well I actually think that
crisis are when you realize how much you
need markets you know the most
terrifying days in 2008 were when
trading completely stopped there markets
that actually suspended trading
absolutely
terrifying because you had no idea what
was going on I remove liquidity from the
process it's the most terrifying moment
in
investing if you think markets are
crisis markets reflect the crisis and in
fact I think they let let us get through
crisis quicker than we did 150 years
ago I'm sure that 1912 crisis where JP
Morgan had to step in and save the US
economy part of it came from the fact
that most companies were not traded you
needed a banker with the Statue to step
in you don't realize how much you miss
markets till they're not there anymore
right I mean I've been Valu Val ation I
tell people look in publicly traded
companies We complain about the
marketing until we get to that last
stage and have this market price to
compare the value to you take that away
it's amazing how much of a crutch you've
lost so I'm not going to try to convince
you that markets are are perfect they're
not they're very imperfect but they're
making immediate I mean think about it
this morning you're trying to make a
judgment on how this tariff war will
play out on the US economy on the global
economy across companies and markets are
trying economists will work through a
three-year process and three years from
now there'll be a research paper on the
2024 Trump tariff plan and how it plays
by that time you read the paper you've
already seen what happens I appreciate
the fact that I get this real time
response noisy though it is which brings
me to my third and final thing which is
I think where much much of the fighting
in the last two decades has happened
which is a social CA and again in theory
social cause and social benefits don't
exist because we assume the way in
practice decisions are full of side
effects or
externalities as economists prefer to
call them and we've wrestle what do we
do about
them now I'll give you the challenge
with social cost and social
benefits for the most part you don't
know them until you hit them I'll give
you as an example consider a company
that in the 1940s and 50s comes up with
this incredibly light material to work
within building and remember those days
building construction you know steel was
Heavy you know what I'm talking about
right aluminum and John Manel when it
came out people thought that was an
amazing
product it was only 20 or 30 years later
maybe 15 years later
that we discovered that it caused cancer
what if we find out I'm at all these
devices on me right now I have a watch I
have an iPhone we find out 10 years from
that destroys your your IQ drops by 10
points every year by the time we get to
15 years from now we're know we're all
we've all lost all our brain power we
can sue but what are we going to do with
the you know by then it's too late what
I'm trying to say is when people think
about social cause they think about bad
companies great social CA good companies
don't that's not true because a lot of
CA we don't know until after the fact so
I don't mean to sound like Donald
Rumsfeld but you cannot know the unknown
at the time you make decisions there are
social costs you create without even
knowing you're creating them at the time
of the decision making
second social cost are in the eyes of
the
beholder what you think is a big social
cost might be a small one for
me so we're sitting around a table
trying to decide in a project we let
everybody bring their social cost down
we're going to have decision paralysis
because each of us is going to have a
different agenda we're pushing for
because there is no consensus here
that's going to play out but every
Company claims to be a good company they
want I mean take a look at the annual
report it's amazing how much of the
annual report describes how good this
company is for the world so there like
20 pages of financials and 150 pages of
beautiful pictures of the employees
working with the homeless and look at
how much good we do and if you and I I
understand but if you really mean what
you say then I want to see some numbers
okay so let's suppose you take Disney
and Disney talks about how how much it
cares about communities and wants to
create employment and places where there
you know there are no jobs so let's
suppose and this was the day when
Disney's still at stores that I
suggested them that they open a new
Disney Store store in Downtown
Oakland have any of you been in Downtown
Oakland pretty much no shopping left
right it's kind of and I said look
you're going to do this and if you do
this I'm going to cut out all the pr
stuff so I'm going to remove that we're
going to run ads on we have a store in
Downtown Oakland to get you to buy so
let's cut all of this out because this
is all about goodness let's make it
about goodness you're going to lose a
million dollars every year from doing it
so let's say you are Disney management
and I have your annual report in front
of me where you told me how good you are
and I told you that the story how many
of you would be willing to open the
store good I'm glad I'm glad so and so
because you're staying true to what what
the company says word would you also be
willing to share that cost with your
shareholders see that's what I don't get
right if you want to be if you want to
if you want to be generous with other
people's money but because it's and the
reason you say probably not is they
probably won't go along with it why are
we so quick to make that judgment right
because if you're a company with a good
history my guess is you can essentially
get this by them because they're okay if
you're a company with a bad history your
stock has been down 50% you probably
don't even want to try but I'm glad you
said yes because that's what I would
expect to see companies willing to spend
money being good because if you say no
I'm not going to open the store let's
cut these 100 pages out of your annual
report let's stop this stupid dance it's
a public relations dance it really does
nothing for society nothing for the
world it just is this look how good we
are I don't know about you but I've run
into a lot of good people in my lifetime
you know one thing they share I've never
heard them tell me how good they
are I mean if you can go back and look
at all of the years that Mother Teresa
made all those speeches I thinking
anyone she got up and said look I'm a
good person your actions speak for
yourselves so when people talk about
doing good I want to see some heft
behind it tell me you're spending money
and that you your shareholders have gone
along with it because you have the fat
to burn off you've done well enough for
that so I'm going to set up what where
we've done we've dug a hole for
ourselves or at least I've dug a hole
for myself in what sense I've taken
every linkage in the utopian world
and I've destroyed it basically it says
doesn't work doesn't work which leaves
us with a question of what do we do next
so next session when we start we're
going to say are is there a better way
to run businesses so I'm going to give
you three choices perhaps a non
stockholder based corporate governance
system somebody else follows the second
maybe pick a different objective rather
than maximize stock prices Revenue
growth market share and the third is
stay with maximizing stock prices but
with safety vales something to protect
us from all those so I will leave you
thinking about those choices but I'd
like you to think about all the big
issues that came out today and we'll
talk about more and once